[Music]
this weekend the Final Four is gonna
take place right here in Dallas now a
fun part of the games is watching the
team mascots doing slam dunks a lot of
colleges in Texas some of them have very
strange mascots here's what we did we
invited some of the freakiest mascots
from all over the great state of Texas
to come dunk on our show tonight so it's
time that isn't comin for our NC
double-a weird dunking mascots
Lindemann first up as a mascot that
blends a popular african-american
filmmaker with a well-known Texas
politician please welcome Tyler Perry's
Rick Perry are you ready turn the
prairies Rick Perry
that was horrifying yeah the governor
has sat in purple panties yes at one
time our next mascot was a mascot for
the Texas Rangers
that's right it's a rods last known vial
of clean urine
Wow 1976 that's a long time you're ready
clean urine
[Music]
[Applause]
no I saw up the pill bottle that was
horrified next an all-too-familiar site
around here the guy who ate too much
tex-mex oh boy
credible muscle control incredible
muscle control alright let's see if you
can do it go
[Applause]
that was almost tragic the toilet almost
became separated from his body
Oh shamelessly pander to the people here
in Dallas at the expense of another
great Texas city here's another one the
Austin hipster being gored by a bull put
me down in the vegan man I'm bleeding
cappuccino Arcade Fire tickets okay
that's fine basketballs a metaphor for
corporate down shut up oh isn't he dead
yet
someone put artisanal toast in my mouth
oh shut up
our final best shot used to do lots of
deep drilling before developing an
embarrassing personal problem it's the
oil derricks suffering from erectile
dysfunction
stay there dude
[Applause]
[Music]
you know what L well this is just awful
I think get him out of here yeah get him
out of here fast I think we got we gotta
have someone get it in and I think that
should be Tyler Perry's Rick Perry I
think he might actually be able to go
let's bring him back it's on you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's got my vote
[Applause]